um hello Melissa this is my first video
ham direct upload ever though I don't
really know what I'm doing but I wanted
to say thanks for becoming a nerdfighter
nerdfighters and also for becoming a
secret sibling because that's really
cool to have a high profile user as
yourself as secret sibling additionally
I'm very excited that you are also
becoming a partner because that means
that there's going to be somebody that I
know from YouTube on the conference call
that is coming up whenever it's coming
up and that's cool I mean it sort of is
I feel like I'm part of the larger
YouTube community you might be like we
are you're part of this sort of big
amazing crazy thing called YouTube and
that is very exciting anyway obviously
your background is nicer than my
background I just have some you know my
basement ceiling mostly and also
somebody snowballs I have a map of the
world right here and it was it's I took
it it was up on Robin I took it down a
while ago so I could have a blank white
space and I should put this world
because it's like an oozy and hold it
here against my head yeah see though
it's very official yes excellent well I
wanted to say thank you for the cute
little nerdfighter shrinky dink yes I do
in fact remember shrinky dinks and and I
think I may have had an into turtle
shrinky dinks when I was a kid we are
not right if you think that you're too
old for YouTube then I am way too old
for YouTube because I got like four
years on you easy maybe three so yeah
thank you that was an excellent shrinky
dink it worked very well I I was like
you can't put crayons on triggy tink
it's going to melt it's going to melt
and there won't be any colour and she'll
be sad and it'll just be a burned blob
of burned crap but yeah we're truly well
congratulations you proved me very wrong
so
yeah thank you and that was cool and I
can't wait to Hue your current affairs
nerdfighter song or see it in the in my
pants um and I'll see you soon
and I'll keep watching your videos if
you keep watching mine later fight